I would like to take a personal moment
to say hello to someone who inspired me
to host this show I've done it four
times now he did it 17 times he's 90
years old this year and I just want to
say to him a thanks for the inspiration
ladies and gentlemen sitting right over
here mr. Bob Hope
now please welcome one of the most
talented people I know a very good
friend of mine it was a fantastic
stand-up comedian and Academy Award
winning actress she has her own talk
show in this year she got in a habit and
sang Motown and she was even mentioned
as a possible attorney general nominee
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
fabulous Whoopi Goldberg
after all it is Hollywood this
adaptation of am forced his beautiful
novel is filled with passionate men and
women headstrong and intelligent these
free spirits ignore the rules of class
that govern Edwardian England with
far-reaching consequences they are led
by three remarkable women each a little
mad in her own way
all of them bound to the place called
Howards End you welcomed her in
Groundhog Day
now welcome her on Oscar night Andie
MacDowell
earlier Barberini welcomed us to magic
time and if any of you doubts that
motion pictures are magic
you haven't been to once it's movie
theaters came in six packs today's
studio Wizards can accommodate any
writers imagination or directors desire
to defer nurse that magic it was another
great year for the Wizards and the three
films nominated for best achievement in
visual effects are alien 3 in which
Richard Edlund Alec killers Tom Woodruff
jr. and George Gibbs took these great
pains to create greater pains for
Sigourney Weaver Batman Returns Michael
Fink
Craig Baron John Bruno and Dennis botas
multiplied one sweet little penguin with
the computer and divided him to a
battalion bad birds death becomes her
Ken Ralston and Doug king
Doug's my and Todd Woodruff jr. used
blue screen photography and computer
technology to turn more heads than Meryl
Streep's and the Oscar goes to Ken
Ralston Doug king Doug smite the tongue
with your tuner for death becomes her
I'd like to thank the Academy
congratulate Bob Zemeckis Steve Starkey
and all the artists at Industrial Light
and Magic including Bruce Paquito
Steve jolly Pat Turner Peter Dalton and
thank Patti Blau Debbie Denis the ILM
art department the model shop my mom and
dad and Liz Hanks and all my wonderful
friends and on behalf of my partner Alec
Gillis who cannot be up here because of
a coin toss and our crew including Yuri
and Gino and Stan Winston and I'd like
to thank everyone at ILM including
especially Gail curry Lincoln who Judith
Weaver Andrew Schmidt Jeff Campbell Joe
Pasquale Iran Roland Alex Adams G
bromine and Thank You sandy carbon thank
you very much
that's a new record that's a new record
and it's great to see the Osmond
Brothers back together again